make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and before we start this video i
do want to talk to you guys about tko
studios now
this is not a brand deal right i'm not
being paid to talk to you guys about
this
uh the only reason why i'm really
working with them or at least while i'm
advertising them is because tko studios
had this awesome idea
called binge reading right so imagine
like like doomsday clock for example for
dc comics right it took three years for
a comic to come out when it was only
supposed to take 12.
but imagine if you got it all at one
time and that's what they're
experimenting with right so and
those of you guys who are new to comic
books traditionally you get what are
called floppies right just the
individual comics and those will be
released usually like once a month
depending on the publisher marvel will
do it once a month dc will do it twice a
month
depending on the comic is what they did
at the beginning of dc rebirth
um and and and the idea is that over the
course of some period of time
you get the first you get six issues
which basically collect a volume right
usually six issues to a particular story
arc
um what tko studios is kicking around is
the idea of
instead of saying that you have to wait
six months to get all six issues
you just get them all at once it's an
awesome idea right because i love being
able to just sit and just binge through
an entire story at once i do it all the
time now with stories that are finished
i love that idea i do think that doing
that
kind of removes the suspense right like
the feeling you're being left on a
cliffhanger
and the excitement of like going and
reading the new issue as soon as it
comes out
i do believe it kind of kills that off
so i think that's a little bit of a
lackluster thing but they have ways to
work around that
the long and short is you should go
check them out right they're really kind
of pitching a lot of these ideas
that look like they will be the future
of comics i'd say in the next five years
or so
so uh so they're pretty solid right make
sure you guys check out sentient there's
a whole bunch of others they sent me all
kinds of other books too
right so they're awesome make sure you
guys take a look and uh
yeah let's talk about maestro being too
powerful
for the marvel cinematic universe here's
the thing about maestro hulk
right maestro hulk is a guy
who we in the comic book community refer
to as
broken this guy is so
op right now here's here's the funny
thing here's the funny thing about this
i still say to this day that in age of
ultron
we never found out what it was that
bruce banner saw because bruce banner
saw maestro
and like they're gonna use him at a
future point in time i say this because
here in the next
week or two at the time that we're
recording this video um
marvel's releasing a one-shot comic on
the origin of maestro there's no reason
to do that right maestro has been dead
in marvel comics for a little while he
was killed by old man logan i think so
he's been gone for a while i don't
really see a means to bring him back
unless they decide to
yank him from the past again or
something like that um the only reason i
can think that they're going to be doing
an origin story on maestro is because
we're going to get maestro in the mcu
now
why does that matter okay the maestro is
a version of the hulk that became
popular during the events of future
imperfect in that storyline that was
released by peter david
back in the 1990s future imperfect dealt
with a place called dystopia right and
the idea was that at about 100 years
into the future or at least
leading up to 100 years from now society
was going to engage in what was a
you know basically a nuclear holocaust
right like pretty much all life on earth
was going to be obliterated
those survivors ended up taking
residence in a place called dystopia
which was ruled by the incredible hulk
now the difference here is
that maestro possessed all the
intelligence of bruce banner
combined with all the strength of the
incredible hulk and the idea was that he
had become
increasingly stronger because of the
fact that he had absorbed all this
nuclear radiation now
it's important to understand how hulk's
power works because this is something
that's consistently misunderstood in
comics across the board right at least
by people who are non-comic readers or
are not familiar with the incredible
hulk
so if we say that like bruce banner gets
angry
and turns into the hulk right so let's
say that like somebody somebody runs up
on him is like hey hulk and it's like
it's like what it's like your mom is so
fat her blood type is ragu right he's
just like
you know like he hulks out and loses his
mind right like he destroys whoever that
person is
and then he kind of goes forward from
there say for example it takes no effort
to kill that guy
right like all hulk has to do is just
like that so we can say
this is baseline hulk right that's hulk
in his base
anger level right that's that's is as
unangry as he could be
but still remain the incredible hulk now
his his strength begins increasing
proportional to his anger right so the
angrier he gets the stronger he gets and
there's no limit to how strong the
incredible hulk can get
the the the strongest we ever saw him
was during
um greg pack's run which you'll find
down in the
in the description you'll find the whole
greg pack incredible hulk run which is
amazing
the strongest uh version of the hulk
that we saw was at the end of that run
when we got heart of the monster hulk
right where bruce banner found a wishing
well
and he basically just ended up being
transported to the realm of dormammu
which is being ruled by his sister at
the time umar
and literally was him and she hulk were
like just destroying the fabric of
reality fighting each other right like
it was it was stated during dr strange
or with it was stated by doctor strange
during that story
that he was way beyond world breaker at
that point right i mean it's just like
this colossal hulking beast right it's
just
this massive thing it's one of the
coolest comic panels
ever right he's just like he's standing
there just like you know like it's it's
it's amazing
but the idea here is that where bruce
banner as the incredible hulk is at a
certain level of strength when he's in
his base form
maestro is above that right so just in
his base you know least angry form
maestro's stronger than baseline hulk
now that's also important because
during future imperfect what you ended
up getting was rick jones who in the
comics is a friend of bruce banners
uh but at that point was like an old man
who was more or less leading this this
kind of rebellion of sorts
and they actually ended up using the
time platform of the villain dr doom
basically a time machine device to go
back into the past and grab professor
hulk now professor hulk
you guys probably recognize him from the
marvel cinematic universe in the comics
he's a combination of most of bruce
banner's personalities
all kind of manifested into one well
really i think it's just gray hulk and
uh
and savage hulk the green hulk who merge
into basically with bruce banner
and so it's bruce banner with his
intelligence and all the powers of the
hulk
without the infinite strength and so
because of that uh they basically end up
bringing professor hulk
into future imperfect and uh and maestro
beats the crap out of him right like a
fight breaks out between the two of them
there is this funny moment when uh the
incredible hulk shows up and like
professor hulk shows up and confronts
maestro
and he's he's like i think either that
or it's like some henchmen or something
but he's like
he's like gentlemen you'll be pleased to
know the doctor is in
but professor hulk he goes to town on
some villains right and then like
big daddy maestro steps up and like
professor hulk gets
crushed i mean not even by a little bit
either right he gets just
dude he gets it handed to him in the in
the most insane way
and it's kind of cool right because my
shirt was just like this this hulk with
like
long long hair like long white hair he's
just enormous he's got these cool little
bead things around his neck he looks
like akuma
from street fighter like it's awesome
right and so so anyway
he beats the living piss out of the
incredible hulk and then like breaks his
neck in the process
right so hulk's just like incapacitated
his recovery was like the greatest
recovery ever right he's just like
surrounded by beautiful women
you know like tending to his every need
i don't know if he could feel anything
which would suck if that was the case
but but nonetheless like he's basically
just kind of recovering and my show is
actually trying to bring him to his
cause and saying that like
humans deserve to be ruled over because
they're weaker than us a second fight
breaks out hulk loses again
it's it's the thing about maestro is he
at least peter david
explicitly stated he wanted my show to
kind of be this insane future version of
the hulk
but my show ended up taking on his own
personality right where he was just like
this kind of warlord right like this
this kind of dictatorial warlord guy
and he was fun and he was cool to read
about because he was the answer to the
question what would happen if one
the incredible hulk turned evil and two
the incredible hulk was power hungry
right like just like power man
what would that version of the hulk look
like and that was maestro now
you take that version of the hulk and
you throw him into the marvel cinematic
universe
i can promise pretty much all of them
would fall
the only person that i think could
probably go toe-to-toe with maestro hulk
now that i think about it
would probably be thanos right because
as far as i'm aware
i don't believe maestro hulk has
infinite strength in
in the comics right i think his strength
just kind of caps out at a certain point
i might be wrong about that um honestly
it's been a long time since i read
maestro
but thanos and the marvel cinematic
universe i mean this guy was able to
just
decimate hulk like by himself right like
by himself now one thing to understand
the difference between the marvel
cinematic universe and the comics
is that the characters in the mcu are
scaled down by a huge margin
right if you took thanos from the comics
and you put him in the marvel cinematic
universe
not only would he decimate the marvel
the mcu version of thanos he would
decimate the avengers
like that like we wouldn't i can't snap
there we go somebody snapped for me um
he would decimate like the the avengers
on earth right like thanos in the comics
is
wildly powerful i mean you're talking
about a guy who can manipulate cosmic
energy you're talking about a guy
who technically can't die he's had
augmentations given to him by death he
fought
fought galactus to a standstill i mean
that's the kind of thanos you're talking
about now his power is waxing waned over
the years but nonetheless it's not a
thanos video
it's a maestro video the maestro is is
hulk in the extreme
right and it would be cool to know that
during the the events of age of ultron
that when the scarlet witch was
manipulating bruce banner
and she forced him to see himself that
he basically saw a point where humanity
basically destroyed himself and you kind
of get this image of maestro because
i in in my mind's eye i imagine how this
looks right that you have like um
i don't know you have like like you
delve into the mind of bruce banner
right the way the same way you got those
flashbacks of those visions with like
uh you know captain america and black
widow and that kind of thing
but with with hulk like as soon as
banner teleports basically or kind of
experiences this vision
it's just like fire and it's just you
know screaming and and
and and like nuclear bombs falling you
know all this kind of stuff or whatever
the case is and then it's just
then then like you see it right like you
see this version of himself
you know this this maybe is he's like
mostly you know shrouded in darkness
until he turns around and looks at bruce
right and then just like he's looking
directly at him and he's like i become
you like you become me
that kind of a thing but it's just like
this great big huge hulking guy who's
just
in total control over dystopia and like
dominates the wills of humans right they
don't have anywhere to go or nothing
they can do
they just do whatever he tells them to
um is to me
that's like the worst version that's
like the worst possible future for
banner right because banner's
largely a pacifist right he's a guy who
doesn't really want to fight and even in
the marvel cinematic universe in in the
first avengers film
he referred to the hulk as the other guy
right like he was more or less scared of
the incredible hulk
you take the incredible hulk as as bruce
banner was afraid of him and you take
the incredible hulk as someone being a
relatively gentle creature
until you piss him off and then you take
him and you amp him up right you amp his
power up
almost in the extreme right to a much
higher level and then you make him power
hungry you make him insane and you make
him evil
it's the most horrifying future that
bruce banner could envision for himself
right
his whole persona run amok because then
it begs the question you know
how does all that work with regards to
bruce is he like a slave in his own mind
and his intelligence is just being used
there's some cool elements about my show
that not even marvel has explored over
the years and so
you know you take a guy like that you
put him in the mcu i can promise you
he'll crush pretty much everybody but
the important thing to also understand
here
is the model cinematic universe roster
is expanding right so with the
introduction of moon knight
also comes the god khan shu who moon
knight basically praises
you've got uh you've got bast who's the
panther god of black panther that could
possess him at any point in time
and then you got black panther running
around with the power of a god you have
adam warlock who's not too far off who's
wildly powerful in his own right
you still got thanos probably hanging
around there somewhere they can just use
him or they can just snatch him out of
time
and call it a day or whatever the case
is for him you know because the rumor is
it's not the last of them but there are
characters who are coming up on the
scene right they have fantastic four
coming which means that they're going to
have franklin richards somewhere along
the line a little reality warping kid
maestro will get crushed by him um
you've got the x-men you've got deadpool
coming so there's going to be
some some powerhouse characters coming
to the marvel cinematic universe
that by the time they introduce maestro
if they do
could definitely give him a run for his
money right and could certainly present
a scenario where
the fight between them and maestro
dwarfs the fight between thanos and the
avengers right because maestro is a
one-man army
this guy's a wrecking crew right that's
that's literally all he is right he just
exists
to destroy things and it's and it's cool
it's just this awesome concept so
i don't know let me know what you guys
think down in the comment section right
about maestro and the marvel cinematic
universe because
i i think i think in a lot of ways
there's only maybe a couple characters
right now in the mcu that could be
brought back really only one character
that could be brought back and used and
that would be thanos right if they found
a way to return him
and then basically put him on a
collision course with maestro he's the
only one that i could think of that
could go toe-to-toe and how cool would
it be
right if like maestro shows up the
avengers are panicking he's just like
crushing everybody it's like what do we
do it's like we do the only thing we can
do
we go and get thanos and they basically
find a way to free thanos they bring
them back
and they have them fight maestro and
it's just this coal like this colossal
battle how many of you guys would want
to see that thanos and the marvel
cinematic universe
versus maestro hulk how many of you guys
want to see that because i know i would
oh i pay all the money in the world to
go see that it'd be
amazing but anyway guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you